in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Ronald
and Stephanie are with us hey guys how
are ya hey Dave how you doing man I'm
awesome welcome welcome good to have you
where you all from from Atlanta Georgia
that's our second Atlanta visit today
yeah for a debt free scream I assume
that's why you're here yes sir how much
have you paid off paid off one hundred
and forty four thousand seven hundred
ninety three and some change in about
eighty four months Wow
awesome making what kind of money during
that time we started off about 63 and
got up to about 126 doubling your
incomes not a bad plan
yes sir so what do you guys do for a
living I'm a transportation supervisor
UPS and I'm assistant registrar at a
four-year private institution in Atlanta
oh very cool which one
Mercy University oh yeah excellent good
good very cool so a hundred and
forty-five thousand dollars what did you
people buy we timeshares student loans
we had credit cards braces whole bunch
of stuff man there's a one hundred forty
five thousand dollars worth of that
stuff yes sir what was the biggest debts
the biggest debt was probably the
timeshare really what you own that hmm
that was about 40 oh my gosh that's a
golden plated time okay oh my gosh so
seven years yes sir
what happened 84 months ago tell us your
story well in about actually I heard
about you about in 2006 one of my
drivers came to me and say hey I know I
heard about this guy Dave Ramsey said
check him out so I wrote it down on a
sticky note uh-huh stuck it in a drawer
never looked at it again socome 2008 I
was driving it on we were living in
Detroit at the time I was driving a
metro area and I saw this sign and said
Dave Ramsey said like extra wage or
something like that I'm like I've heard
that name before so I go back home I
look in the drawer and there's that same
sticky notes you don't they're still
there your name well dust
so I went and you came on the radio so I
think it was 103 5 up there so yesterday
in a radio show bought the Total Money
Makeover read the book in a day and a
half go home and said hey this is
something that we need to do and the
rest was history
stephannie he comes in talking about all
this stuff and you go listen you've been
driving this truck what are you coming
in here telling me this for I can't
actually remember my response when he
came with it but I do remember the three
and a half hour budget meeting the first
budget maybe we had a summit it was
three and a half hours Dave so uh why
just going over everything you know
trying to get the budget together asking
questions you know just putting
everything out there on the table what
we needed to do was it bloody no no no
that survived yeah it was actually
pretty good okay it's tough it's just
kind of cleansing man yeah okay get it
all out on the table now we got to work
on this yes sir when you added it all up
that first time you saw 145,000 did you
know ahead of time that was that big or
did you have a whoa no we didn't know it
was that big now we didn't we really
didn't know but that day until yeah we
started adding it up so now seven years
later boy when you look back over that
versus when you were sitting there
looking at you were at the bottom of the
mountain looking up now you're at the
top of the mountain looking down was it
easier or harder than you thought it was
going to be it was a little bit of both
what was the hardest part the hardest
part was just not being able to spend
you know like you because I like to shop
so he had to kind of we had to kind of
table down the shopping for seven years
yeah the budget you know it wasn't it
wasn't happening so that was the hardest
part
Wow was it worth it oh definitely worth
it now I'm still trying to pinch pennies
and then he's like sweetheart you don't
have to we could kind of relax a little
bit now so we like 126,000 will any
payments right there okay yeah lived
like no-one else now we can live and
give like no one else definitely so you
did all this from the Total Money
Makeover
in the radio show yeah well we did we
actually did we went to FPU oh yeah yeah
we went to waxey I got the home version
first uh-huh
but uh Stephanie wasn't really into the
home versions I was basically watching
it by myself but then we actually went
to the class a local church when we live
in the Detroit did the classroom we went
to the class together and then that sped
up things yeah so what's the class
better when you got there Stephanie oh
yes it was awesome it was nice to have
other people who are following the same
program and to have the accountability
partners and just get a little bit more
momentum to help us to reach our goals
well it makes you feel a little more
normal
because you think you're the only one
that's done dumb with money and then
when you get in there you go oh there's
all these other people too dumb to look
at that you know and so you can you can
work your way out of that that way very
cool so what is your all's key advice
for getting people out of debt I would
say well God first and also um having an
awesome partner you have to do it
together there's no way that we would
have been able to do this no way I would
have been able to do this without her
support so that's huge you do seem like
you kind of get along I love the fact
you guys went to the home study and you
also did the class that's very good for
our listeners to hear the glass in the
home studying the rustle between the two
and the advantages of that
accountability like you talked about
what about those times when you didn't
feel like there was hope you couldn't
see the end in sight you ever have any
moments like that and how did you get
through that oh yeah there were
definitely times where we saw that there
was no end in sight but I'm going to the
class FPU in class really helped and we
also attended the smart conference in
Dallas about two years ago the very
first so we were able you know just
being able to go to those events helped
us to kind of build the momentum that we
needed yeah and stay motivated whoo-hoo
inspired
that's very cool yeah well you guys are
fun
the fact I mean this is most people
can't stick with stuff in our culture
for seven days much less seven years
you guys are impressive very very
impressive that you did what it took to
kid and I got to tell you it's worth it
because you got and you got a great
income you
no payments you're gonna be you're gonna
be able to give and you're gonna be able
to live I mean like nobody else you
really aren't congratulations thank you
very cool all right
Ronald and Stephanie from Atlanta
Georgia a hundred and forty five
thousand dollars paid off in eighty four
months making sixty three when they
started seven years later making a
hundred and twenty-six count it down
let's hear a debt free scream alright
three two one
you